this is Kenya's Masai Mara one of
Africa's great natural wonders filled
with the wonder of life but these days
political unrest has scared away many
tourists and fewer visitors means less
revenue to protect the animals that live
here the nearly 600 square mile reserve
is funded by entrance fees and private
donations
last year thousands of people came to
the Mara now numbers have dwindled
hotels are shut down and workers are
without jobs and as Kenya's civil unrest
continues the Mara and its animals face
an uncertain future
teams go out everyday to combat the
threat of poachers but with funds drying
up the reserve can't afford the manpower
they need security patrols are being
limited the worry is that poachers will
fill the vacuum left by fewer Rangers
this is joseph kimochi no he hunts daily
for snares that either kill animals or
leave them maimed and vulnerable to
attack from predators slow and animal
and animal is glowing and understand me
end up holding the neck
oh maybe pulling it with his legs being
caught in a snare and left to die is a
painful grueling death
Brian Heath director of the Mara
Conservancy says he has less money now
to combat poachers the biggest effect
has been in the huge reduction in
tourists an almost instantaneous drop
about 80% and the numbers of tourists we
rely on our share of revenue to maintain
the politic meet our expenses to cover
security and operational costs so it had
a huge impact on our ability to operator
this patrol manages to apprehend some
suspects and scare off others back at
base the Rangers discovered the men are
not from Kenya but from neighboring
Tanzania this suspect says he's a 40
year old father of 8 children who needs
to hunt in order to feed his kids and
pay for their school fees
his hunting partner says he has six
children to support they both say they
had no other way to make a living the
men claim this is their first foray into
the Maasai Mara but the Rangers don't
believe it
the suspected poachers are led away they
may face a prison sentence or a fine
they cannot afford to pay poaching is
not a lucrative profession the meat from
an entire hippo will generate only about
a hundred US dollars by comparison the
Rangers may be in line for a bonus as an
incentive they receive extra money each
time they apprehend a poacher Josef
blogs about his experience as a ranger
his blog gets more than a thousand hits
a day and readers in Japan recently
contributed some twenty three thousand
dollars in a single month it may be the
reserves only hope and recouping lost
revenue I think we're on the edge of a
crisis I know that all of the wildlife
management authorities in this country
both privates such as the Mara
Conservancy and the kws while facing
drastic cuts to their budget to the
point where clearly they don't have the
presence on the ground anymore now how
quickly this will be taken up that they
can start poaching again remains to be
seen
hopefully the crisis will be short-lived
and in the meantime we have to find ways
of finding alternative funding these
days fewer people may be seeing this
spectacular Reserve in person but
perhaps through the world wide web they
will experience the Masai Mara and
understand it needs global support
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium